l'intervention sur le plan exploitation
et investissement de concorde fait
partie de ces interventions que l'état
juge nécessaire dans les circonstances
présentes au nom de quoi monsieur le
ministre long du prestige le problème
n'est pas de prestige et je vous disais
tout à l'heure qu'il faut ramener
l'intervention qui concerne concorde à
de justes proportions
même si concorde de demain s'arrêter
les deux tiers de l'intervention
financière resterait néanmoins
nécessaire pour faire face à l'aspect
investissement est en réalité
l'intervention de l'état si concorde eux
continuent ne représente donc environ un
tiers du montant qui est prévu pour le
fonctionnement de concorde dans les
trois années à venir